greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by my family at it supplements
weights [ __ ] elk what am i mean
listen you want to get in shape you want
to get your mind right go to Hannah calm
right now take a look at the Alpha brain
if you don't like it if it don't help
you out after 2-3 weeks you can return
it we don't even want the [ __ ]
product will sign your checks who does
that in this business who does that in
this industry on it because they believe
in what they saw go to Hana calm right
now impress in church BAM and get 10%
off delivered right to the [ __ ] Casa
you understand me you can't beat that
you have to leave the house and go to
some [ __ ] health food store that your
[ __ ] house kind of parked some guy in
front he's got a [ __ ] twitch you
don't leave that [ __ ] number two you're
going to use Jitsu you want to get you
going to movie tie a kittycat
listen get yourself some [ __ ] Fuji
sports.com right there the shin guards
the boxing gloves the [ __ ] gezond
tougher than death he understand me
they're bulletproof
nobody even tells you that [ __ ] I'm a
fat [ __ ] people call me in that guard
they're hanging on me my collar
I got fingerprints and nothing the ghee
still comes home and it's beautiful and
it's washed intact why tough these
Japanese people don't [ __ ] around when
it comes to the gear you understand me
anyway go to Fuji sports.com right now
press in charge and get 10% off
delivered to your house and you're
helping out the church kick this [ __ ]
melee are you [ __ ] not so why'd you
thought the hell yeah you know and
Jamie's got a gun [ __ ] Jamie's got a gun
this was never doing heavy duty Chinese
heroin people were jumping off [ __ ]
buildings you understand me
it's Wednesday the 15th I got beautiful
Jimmy Florentine in-studio Jersey's best
goddamn did that sound good then in the
holy [ __ ] why does it sound good after
40 years why it's not supposed to I'm
supposed to listen to that and go really
Joey that again some of the stuff stood
the test of time them you some of it
sounds a little dated I gotta be I I say
this a lot and people freaked out some
of the Beatles stuff to me sounds a
little dated yes it does it sounds that
you like you put it on that I got a
yellow submarine like some of those
songs hard day's night I don't know it
just doesn't it doesn't do it for like
if you just don't put that on now
you're like I don't really get it but
something like that it sounds like it
was recorded yesterday are you ever in
the mood for it even though it's dated
or you can't listen to it at all I can't
really listen to it all my god you know
there are some songs obviously but
there's some that just didn't they don't
they don't sound fresh yesterday I went
over to my favorite [ __ ] record store
over here in Burbank atomic atomic went
over one night last time with Henry
Rollins was him I told Henry I usually
go to a time extraordinary yesterday I
had these albums at the house I had
doubles your get doubles of [ __ ] people
give you on the road I went and picked
up Oh
Darkseid look at this oh if you want
like you got it Pat Benatar that's a
good one first foreigner rumors Stevie
Nicks the first one but I had to take
this one this is a [ __ ] master like
this those Beatle albums once they
discovered the marijuana and the heroin
and he started eating that [ __ ] now
Yoko Ono's [ __ ] it changes like
everything [ __ ] change that's what
happened yo kimonos [ __ ] next another
word in Chinese don't say Jude
revolution paperback writer I should
have known better lady Madonna can't buy
me love don't let me down
bowel of John and Yoko rains this [ __ ]
from I think revolver I don't know the
exact thing give it a listen to give it
a listen to just put it on YouTube one
day that [ __ ] that see them but can't
buy me love and all that I wipe my ass
with that [ __ ] it's like no they're dead
look there's some [ __ ] hated this I
love all this [ __ ] the bad cops I love
all this I read the man who led Zeppelin
and he only manages Led Zeppelin yeah so
I got back into bed call me the two
bands over on swan song yeah as music
fans even though it let's say you don't
like the Beatles do you still respect
them looking back seeing what they were
able to do or you just like no you're an
idiot if you say to you no you can't
respect the Beatles and The Beatles
weren't that were overrated and we're
not good I was just more of a stones guy
because of my older brothers bought that
[ __ ] in the house whatever they brought
in I liked and they brought more two
stones and the Beatles are you
brother still music guys like you yeah
oh yeah hey what we just went to see
Lynyrd Skynyrd's final tour how was it
was phenomenal phenomenal every song my
son knew have to have two [ __ ] songs
every song one after another I noticed
one I know this one I noticed one I know
that what it's unbeliev I've been seeing
them every year
you're a true [ __ ] troupe of love
it's great you go to a concert yeah you
tailgate you have [ __ ] beers in the
park a lot you bother people the guy
coming around trying to sell a bootleg
shirt you [ __ ] with him you know he's
trying to sell me he goes there's $70
inside I goes no they're not
then this has never been a concert
t-shirt that's $70 inside you're selling
it for 30 in the parking lot if I see
you after the show you'll be giving it
to me for $5 give it to me for 10 right
now before you get busted and we just
bust balls and [ __ ] hang out and look
at hot chicks walking by well the
Skynyrd it wasn't really that many hot
chicks but and it's [ __ ] great then
you go into the show you drinking beers
and [ __ ] listen to live music and
they're actually playing nothing better
I don't hike I don't [ __ ] fish you
don't play golf
I don't play God not for that [ __ ] none
not show your hobby is I go to go to
colleges eat and drink some [ __ ]
beers and have a good time I'll tell you
I haven't tailgated for a concert oh we
get there like forney afternoon the
shows it's not till I hear it [ __ ] 8
you know you valet your car whatever the
[ __ ] they do now you know it's a
different experience than hopping on it
buster 248 whatever the [ __ ] box drops
you off at and by the time you got to
the city that acid you took on the
jersey slide and starts to kick in and
you gotta walk to the garden you know
it's like an eight block walk to the
garden I forget what it was that
experience will be etched in my brain
forever I could tear up right now like I
could tear up saying that that's never
gonna happen in my life again where I
still remember going to see ac/dc with
Brian Johnson on a Friday night it was
August 1st 1980
I still remember leaving the lumberyard
at 5:00 going home washing my [ __ ]
calling Kurt God rest his soul and I
made them meet me at 29th Street and New
York Avenue the last must place where
you could take the bus into Jersey
there's a post office down the corner
and there was a guy in his name was Jack
Finn I worked the Irish guy from
Weehawken New Jersey this is my talking
29th in New York 29th to New York Avenue
is borderline Weehawken Union City
because I lived on ground and Gregory
Avenue it's the last place you can take
the bus into Manhattan that's it and
then there's a bar there used to be
called Otto's on the corner and I listen
to me I'll never forget going in there
maybe you know what I have in those days
and we bought a half gram of coke from
Jack Finn Jack Finn was the first person
that I ever saw get coked up and make
faces by the time I started making it
took me 3 4 years to start making faces
and start waiting with my hands
Jack Finn was in 1980 was already
getting creeped up and doing [ __ ] like
when you bring him in front of people
people go what the [ __ ] is his problem
yeah the guy is here he's gonna be right
back he was creepy you ship yeah you got
I'm gonna get you a gram this shit's
great but you gotta leave something for
the mouse you know that's right you
would have to believe in two lines of
code
I still remember being whatever 1980 was
I was 17 and getting on the bus recurred
we bought a pint of blackberry brandy
and an a pack of nips and we tried him
on the [ __ ] bus like you just chugged
them here bus driver didn't say [ __ ] to
you you can be [ __ ] we were kids
drinking those [ __ ] beers on the bus
we split them and then we got our
funding the Port Authority went
downstairs and the whole walk in fact
that was at the Palladium that was not
at the garden ac/dc with Def Leppard
August 1st 1980 we went to the Palladium
and I'll never feel I was just telling
somebody that you had a go was telling
Timmy Holloway that you had a the cool
people the people who knew drugs knew
that if you went behind the Palladium
there was a fence that was ripped down
and you go back there before the show
started and people were back there
banging and drinking oh yeah people
didn't know about that there was a
little fence back there
so me and Kurt this white kid Lee
Lorenzo went back there did a couple
bumps
we finished the blackberry brandy it was
the hottest night ever in New York City
I was at that show the hottest night I
have ever ever experienced so I got
jeans on a t-shirt and ac/dc Def Leppard
came up and destroyed and then they see
or it could be an Iron Maiden it was
either that was a flapper yeah and then
ac/dc came out with the [ __ ] Bell you
know and in those days we used to do
acid and then do blow and we had a
quaalude fillet that I mean it was over
I still remember walking home with such
a high ac/dc was sensational but that's
that was my tailgate and then I started
going to where you were another concert
that I went to that he went to a [ __ ]
Cherry Bomb now is it yet I thought it
has very poor convention hall I had made
the Jews increase that [ __ ] show
because there was a trend the people
throwing [ __ ] cherry bombs and it was
you oh wait y'all firecrackers cherry
bombs and maybes but I never forget
going to see the stones and far enough
Philadelphia at the stadium hfk number
78 and at that point we saw some kinky
[ __ ] but it wasn't till I went to see do
with Sabbath and Sammy Hagar with shakin
Street down at Philadelphia where we
were outside that I tailgated for that
one at the spectrum yeah cause you could
tell there's a back talking louder I
forget tailgating there and we're out
there with the Gebo coke blastin like
[ __ ] like we own the place and all of
a sudden they took this by the heads and
they're like FBI pull open your trunks
we we all had piled around us we all had
[ __ ] quaaludes we had everything on us
they made us open our trunks and they
were looking for shirts the boot like
the bootlegs
the counterfeit shirts and they didn't
care about the drug getting give ship
they searched everything they even found
the package of coke left it nothing
that's the concert where we stopped on
McDonald's and we had like 13 throw but
my buddy came back
he goes look I got six remote seconds
ago what you do with those tickets it
was a trade then I go I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you
these are counterfeit you just got taken
no no they were real Jimmy Florence they
were real they were real woman I'd
rather sit row we were watching people
spit on their fingers and Philadelphia
and fling it at Sammy Hagar Sammy Hagar
was so terrible with shaken Street now
he was on tour at that time and Ronnie
Montrose is on tour on two different
tours so we got to see Sabbath
it wasn't Blue Oyster Cult yet that was
opening for the members and then they
went on the body had a black and blue
yeah this was still Sammy Hagar and I'm
gonna forget us looking around tripping
and people spitting up their face
swinging and Sammy Hagar Sammy Hagar
like duck and spit from [ __ ] people
Philadelphia this is why when I saw the
goober show 30 years later I laughed my
ass off because I go that's nothing
I saw them spitting on their hands yeah
throw the Sammy Hagar who does that [ __ ]
Jimmy said something a couple minutes
ago that it wasn't a good eating it
wasn't a good show to see girls did you
guys ever meet girls at these shows you
didn't give a [ __ ] well four bursted
that ac/dc Def Leppard show I remember
Joe he said that that was the hottest
night in New York okay so me and my
friend took the train in from Jersey
went to walk him back to the garden
after the show we just bought seven
ac/dc shirts we saved all our money we
got the baseball jersey we got them all
cuz we were so excited we're gonna buy
everything so we walking back and we got
mugged by three Puerto Ricans they took
our shirts we're just talking oh my god
was that great Dion called boom we yet
they punches in the head they grab our
shirts and just walk away they're bigger
than us and I remember yelling go where
the [ __ ] are you guys gonna wear those
shirts I'm like what Puerto Rican is
gonna go back to his wherever he is from
I'm gonna wear a [ __ ] ac/dc baseball
jersey the back in black [ __ ] in 1980
tour no one's gonna know that mute and I
then and they just left with our shirts
and that was that concert that Jovi was
at save concerts but yes you girls would
hook up with you at the at the shows
there'll be some girls that would come
to the shows you know I remember I don't
know if I told us so I put it in my book
about the scene of scorpions at the
spectrum I I got front-row somehow was
it a general mission I got all the way
up front
I went to go get some beers and I saw
this hot chick and it seemed like she's
by herself is that hey you want to come
in the front get you in the front we'll
just switch tickets or whatever just
follow me just keep walking like you
know where you are and we'll get right
so I get this girl right in the front
she's a nine on a scale of one to ten
and we're in the front row no scorpions
comes out and we start making out before
it before the scorpions come on I'm like
holy [ __ ] this is great they're on stage
and she starts flashing the banshees
showing her tits and the bands go yeah
give me the thumbs up giving her two
thumbs up I'm feeling her up doing a
show I'm grinding my dick on her ass
we're making out I'm sucking on a neck
why the [ __ ] playing you'll love
drive I'm like this is [ __ ] amazing
I'm gonna let then we get laid after the
show I just met this chick the scorpions
going crazy
right the show ends to bat one of the
roadies comes over he goes hey the
scorpions want to meet you too come on
follow us so I'm like holy [ __ ] we're
gonna go meet the scorpions we get to
the [ __ ] door as a big bouncer there
and she goes first and then I'm going
through he goes no no just her and I got
none outed a scorpion said they want to
meet us good no just her and I don't
know but I'm eager Society just stand in
my way and the girls walking now I think
I named was like Emily or whatever I'm
like Emily Emily they won't let me back
she never even looked back didn't even
look back she was going back through the
drink the blood and I was mad at the
scorpions for taking my girl for like
two years I'm like [ __ ] damn I had a
little radio show them like I'm not
playing and I banned them I mean while I
was like a four on a scale of 1-10 she
was a nine I was just lucky that she
[ __ ] she used me but I'm a poor she's
gonna [ __ ] the scorpions who wouldn't I
don't ever think I hooked up or tried to
hook up with a girl on the show I took a
girl to see Ted and ac/dc at the guard I
was at that job it was 40 before it was
hot as [ __ ] bond went through the crowd
would anger side over the show yeah I
was blown away
I still remember going on the bus for
that show and people had the Jew ghetto
blasters on the bus on the Kennedy
Boulevard bus all the way to 20 I don't
like all the way into New York with
highway to hell blasting that people
just for that show people went to the
show just to hang on outside it was cool
just to hang outside the garden those
even if you didn't have tickets what the
[ __ ] you never know what was gonna
happen you never know what was gonna
happen if you just went over there you
were gonna get it
there's somebody in New York that will
take a fight our bill open up a back
door and go once you're in you're in
it's up to you like in the town number
when they robbed the lemon when they
robbed the Boston Stadium Fenway Park
and the guy goes you never [ __ ] saw
my face okay the same way the guys that
take give me five apiece really we get
in yeah but you got no tickets you're
gonna get stopped so you got a finagle
or you can stand to the side so I
learned that if I took five gorillas I
had a hard time but if I kept my mouth
shut by myself I'd go all the way to the
top for five hours so lot of those shows
I used to go on on a whim like I don't
need a ticket I don't even [ __ ] take
it because I knew you were going and you
bought fourth row tickets so I would
just go into the city and buy $7 red
seats whatever the [ __ ] they were orange
and my goal was to sneak down to you
guys you guys would come up and get me
yeah and just give her an extra ticket
give me an extra ticket well yeah one
guy would sit at the seats and then he'd
bring two stubs up and he would give you
to stub the six and then both you guys
would walk down we've been doing that
for years so it was [ __ ] brilliant
because in my own town if you went to
see Ted a see Judas anybody there was we
ran 40 deep not that we all 50 of us
went together but cliques from different
parts that ADHD part you had 51st street
party at 43rd Street bar yes 64th Street
field so we'd see each other in the city
in fact one of the famous things about
my hometown was one of the guys I think
Randy mergo god bless his soul I had a
North Bergen head on at that show pangas
was real close to the stage Randy took
it off threw it and gets picked it up
and put it on and did a couple things
took it off and threw her back to him
the kid almost had a [ __ ] heart
attack that's the greatest like the kid
almost had a heart attack like was
somebody from Lincoln school something
happens tomorrow
Timmy Holloway will call me and say was
distance oh my god how did you remember
that do you think you like someone has
Pickers from back then
these concerts and you might be in like
I wonder if you guys are in a picture
together and like the crowd or something
how funny would that be it could be
absolutely we would add all those shows
all of them right in the front at the
Palladium to Sabbat that the guard was
Van Halen - I think you went to Harold
Smith at the soap factory when they were
broken
they were just broken broken they were
down to nothing they were like a [ __ ]
worse than like I just you sat there and
said what happened Joe Perry was gone
and there at the soap factory in [ __ ]
this warehouse kind of place that was
just a dump after playing at the
Palladium at the plane at the Garden for
[ __ ] Black Sabbath yeah I'd stayed
why a giant stadium and stuff yeah a
date that they fell that hard I fell
that [ __ ] hard it's so weird I went a
couple weeks ago I was telling you I'm
watching Ted on Joe Rogan and it's
interesting and people make fun of Ted
Nugent then he's got crazy views and he
did some fucked-up [ __ ] let me tell you
something [ __ ] do something
your homework and go back and bust out
Cat Scratch bust out some of their early
Amboy Dukes [ __ ] like some of that [ __ ]
and then just trying on double live guns
oh and all that feeling you had for that
about that crazy shitty talks will
disappear as I know I did I just had to
be reminded it's so weird how he doesn't
know about a lot of people not because
he's dumb or because because these
people are really irrelevant like
there's a guy this guy I want to get on
the show you know this is on that thing
right there Hollywood Henderson yeah I
want to get him on the show if you go to
his Twitter he's got like yeah I need to
get my story out there Hollywood I got
bad news for you first off nobody knows
who the [ __ ] you are I read a wreath out
there and this producer to come on the
podcast I go because nobody knows who
you are
you might walk around thinking people
know who the [ __ ] you are but no one
else are you are you're a forgotten
soldier he went to jail in 1980 that's
right for some coke laughter something
and year run of destroying LA he was
hanging out with Pryor in the Pointer
Sisters Norton Co
a limo at the Comedy Store went to jail
in 1980 1990 came out and he hit the
Texas state lottery not once but twice
really I didn't know that about thirty
million dollars or something so he
opened up a rehab he's clean and sober
but if you go to his Twitter page it
says hey men help me sell my story
sorry Hollywood nobody knows who the
[ __ ] you are and it's a shame when I
watched Steven Tyler and Joe Rogan was
one of the best podcast I've ever won he
was great on there yeah but the thing
that room that came over me the most was
Jesus Christ how many of you people put
on his first album Aerosmith after you
watch that episode the first two three
four albums a masterpiece unbelievable
psoriatic rocks okay you're Wayne gets
you wins at the fourth Aerosmith it's
just and the sad thing is we don't know
them is that like I feel bad introducing
some of those bands cuz I feel odd he's
you know everything today is basically
and even tools like old man
band now now it's getting read again and
you know it moves so quickly what did he
hit the lottery he was he he hit it
I believe in 79 is that true or did he
I'm sorry because he he was in prison
for 28 months and he won twenty eight
million dollars
well the 28 million he was like he hit
it and yeah I'm trying to find the here
you he was the modern day like Marshawn
Lynch Marshawn Lynch is crazy and
everyone knows him that's how Hollywood
Henderson was being on the Cowboys
America's team and he was just nuts he
was like the guy before LT he was like
LT nuts like he was a great player but
he was also crazy always getting in
fights and problems off the field and
stuff he was amazing when he plays but
it was funny because I still remember
when he took the Superbowl he took the
can of Orange Crush and he smashed it
because I'm gonna [ __ ] you up in the
Superbowl you think an Orange Crush and
he smashed it and then the Super Bowl he
intercepted the ball running for a
touchdown
right and like if you read his books
like
you bought a kilo that night no I think
he won the lottery in 2009 yeah twice
Wow
yeah there's in Austin Texas in 2000
twice who wins the [ __ ] lot seeing
people used to delight people other
gangsters mobsters high-ranking mobsters
in the 70s you used to buy lottery thing
you know who else
Whitey Bulger won the lottery twice
because they would put it on the
neighborhood if you hit the lottery let
me know I'll buy the ticket from your
cash and I can clean my money ah really
that's why why they Bulger hit the live
look at whitey Bulger's he hit the lot
of you a couple [ __ ] time even is if
you watch the movie his brother even
says to him one time really whitey again
you hit the [ __ ] lottery for 3
million because they would come up to
Jim Warren Tina going we heard you got
[ __ ] up ticket for 3 mil we'll give
you two milk cash then they probably
stabbed you yeah and they probably give
you a hug a thousand stab you look give
you 20,000 what there's a article from
1995 in the Boston Globe that the FBI or
something federal ordered the lottery to
Commission to withhold a portion of the
14 point three million dollar jackpot
that he won I told you 12 REO from
Goodfellas bought a couple lottery
tickets yeah they paid two million cash
for one happy weightless tell Walsall is
notorious for my father we take a sample
Ivana I didn't know what I did that
that's actually watched a model been
this way I'm washing crazy when I was
[ __ ] 18 I was buying [ __ ]
passports you get a Social Security card
a license and insurance clown yeah I was
getting close like 15 had fake IDs all
that stuff up driver's license in New
Jersey they had no white pictures on yet
away no picture so my brother was five
years old now and you stole the license
from your brother he got a temporary one
then you gave the brother when he lost
back in you carry the temporary yeah he
just says he lost it he do he gives me
his yeah yeah and it was only eighteen
to drink so I was 15 I look at you go
young what sign are you
yeah like Horace
in the [ __ ] joint at least you guys
knew I used to have played that trick on
people with movie theaters and they
would never know I was just asking what
their birthday was I would even ask him
what this time was and the villain
couldn't really didn't think about it
beforehand there was a bar outside like
the Palladium or to garden or somewhere
around there where they were just uh you
know you would 14 years old would just
go in and get pitchers of beer and sit
there before before we go see shows who
were 14 the girl will come over we
wouldn't sit at the bar I was too risky
they know they just get their [ __ ]
kids and then come over yeah good we
need four pitchers of beer beefsteak
Charlie's remember that was next to
Madison Square Garden we used to go to
before a show and drink so much and we
puke into the pitchers and then put them
back and put them back on the table and
then fill them up again cuz
all-you-can-eat beer and food beef steak
Charlie started out good yeah it started
out good and people started getting
business before salmonella yeah people
started walking out of there with their
eyes and falton coming out of their
mouths this [ __ ] and beefsteak Charlie
had like a weird haircut yeah like a
mustache so if you had a weird haircut
in my name but people call you boost a
childlike music what's going on with
that [ __ ] head beef steak child
yeah so so we just get pictures of beer
and but you know that my friends would
puke in them and then put them back on
the table you want more beer you have a
young son right yeah because I my dad
would always we'd always said at the bar
get a Shirley Temple we'd get [ __ ] an
appetizer here do that though they they
won't even let you sit at the bar
anymore no that's crazy I don't give a
[ __ ] if they as soon as they start
serving out for minor cannot be in a bar
anymore
yeah so if we're at the let's say we go
to the comedy store and I bring mercy
with me mercy could hang me at the
Stuart or eight o'clock at 8:01 mercy
has to step for us when as they start a
show I got pulled mercy out of there in
the old days you can at least happen
there yeah you kid could sit next to you
it's [ __ ] different world now bro I
give that's gonna stop you from drinking
oh because a [ __ ] exactly okay can you
guys send you your kids I mean maybe
yours a little older can you send him to
a concert or do you have to go with him
no I could we go together
he might up that the Whitesnake
foreigner and Jason Bonham and Jason
Bono's band does all blood Zeppelin it's
phenomenal and foreigner Whitesnake him
and he he
David Coverdale hain where unlike decide
like up close but I decide and then he
got a set list from the guitar player
brought it over to him during a show
it's the [ __ ] coolest picture I got
to pull it off how old is your son now
he's seven he's gonna be eight on
Saturday you're exposing them to all
this music he just saw a Marilyn Manson
Rob Zombie loved it that wouldn't you
smell weed what does he save you no
one's smoking that much weed
really I like outside there's not too
much going on it's weird you know if
they're doing it's maybe it park a lot
or whatever honor is is Jersey so people
aren't smoking as much weed as they are
out here okay you know so it's still
it's still not totally totally legal
there so people kind of hide and it's
more drinking smell weed once in a while
but you can't even smoke outside it this
is a PNC Arts Center it's in Jersey it's
an outdoor pavilion but you can't even
smoke outside there there's like a
designated area somewhere outside by a
fence where you could smoke cigarettes
and that's it
but inside the venue can't even smoke
and it's outside you know you got a roof
over it but it's still open
I heard you stadium has a designated
spot for smoking weed I don't know how
true it is I don't know what the sources
I don't know if it's it's like you know
you can't you're not supposed to know
about it
this is David Coverdale from Whitesnake
he's walking by and my son reaches out
and he shakes his hand during the show
what was this this is like two months
ago look at David Coverdale don't look
as [ __ ] good still good when they
released the amp
there's a new one there yeah it's coming
out in the fall they pushed it back a
little who's his new people he has a
whole new personnel Tommy Aldridge is
still on drums he's a monster still
looks exactly the same place to hit play
does a drum solo with his hands Tommy
Aldridge he's been around since I was
he's to play in Black Oak Arkansas back
in the day Jesus Christ how old are we
talking about here he's got to be
Saturday May 7 the most he is a 72 I'd
say somewhere 69 to 72 and he's still in
Hannibal on drums he does a drum solo
and he plays with his hands half the
time I called Rudy today see we want to
do some
lunch maybe get some Cuban food and Rudy
was taping something today and some
tomorrow and I thought the phone with
him I'm like I [ __ ] about my [ __ ]
life being busy he's got me by 10 years
or something resource he's unbelievable
the guy's insane that you know just the
way he looks amazing he hasn't aged a
day
in 30 years and he's out there
performing touring with all these bands
doing this playing on this record oh
yeah okay yeah I mean do you guys and I
guess just Jim not bother you but what
it what does it make you how does it
make you feel when you go and see these
people and you remember seeing them as
teenagers when you were teenagers in
their in their 20s or 30s and now there
are 60 70s does it does it affect you or
it inspires me because and you know you
guys a comic you always think okay I
can't do this forever and no one's gonna
give a [ __ ] but you know when you see
these guys still up there and torn and
doing it it's like why couldn't I can't
we do it in our 60s if we really wanted
to not tour as much but still do it like
I always start at some point that people
aren't gonna listen anymore they're not
gonna care but if these guys are doing
it and they still have a fanbase that
grew up with them you know as a comic
you have your fan base that grew up with
you they're gonna get older with you and
they're still gonna want to see you
because it's still gonna bring back good
memories when they were younger but they
can't party as much or other is there
other musicians who still party the same
rarely maybe you know a glass of wine
afterwards or maybe before but they're
not really doing they know it's a
business they you know when you're
getting 350 bucks a ticket you know not
really how much ticket some of them you
know some of them have you said in the
first like 20 rows or so Jesus so Joey
just the guitar player when the
Whitesnake ended they're doing their
vows he took the setlist off the floor
and he ran over cuz he saw my son like
he was the only young kid in the front
and he handed up and I got I pictured
I'd say we hand them to setlist from the
white snake show the guy ran over and
just in Gretton isn't that great that's
amazing that you're exposed and he's
gonna I mean I can't imagine like when
they go away and like what let's play
this song let's play a sweet Caroline
he's
[ __ ] that oh yeah he hates that stuff I
hate that [ __ ] you know what's great
about it like he was he knew like one
foreigner song foreigner songs are so
catchy and so good they're so well
written within like a day and a half he
knew like 3/4 that our setlist all the
hits dirty white boy hot blooded all
that [ __ ] cuz there's such good songs
and they're easy to pick up to listen to
it's almost like ac/dc a lot ECDC songs
are quick like some young person you
want to get them into them something
like tools gonna be too too complex for
them that's like even the old Sabbath
stuff that it's just - it's all over the
place but something like a foreign it
was just it was it was it was great so
he knew it the whole [ __ ] setlist
that [ __ ] - that feels like the first
time [ __ ] the first album [ __ ]
phenomenal as I like that one jam the
[ __ ] one based on the War of the
Worlds there's - [ __ ] great jams on
the first song right war the word world
and it was a Monday oh yeah yeah that's
a good day
Blue Monday what oh my god yeah at first
- that album blew me the [ __ ] away then
the second one is double vision yeah
that little men's of men's but still
great yes no great commercial for me but
still [ __ ] great you know so yeah
yesterday I picked it up why didn't
haven't you ever picked up a [ __ ]
flute I tried everything I got no talent
whatsoever none I tried I tried guitar
all my friends were in bands sets are
hung out what I was a lefty - like I
can't I'm right II can you turn the
guitar around like a No no one could
teach because I was Lefty I tried
singing lessons I went one time the lady
goes look you don't have it I could take
your money but you just don't have any
air for music she told me the first the
FIR after the first lesson I sang with
my friends band like in his garage like
you suck and I'm like yeah I do so I
just I just couldn't play drums I just
don't have any ear for music I love
music but I just don't have the rhythm
for my son's got it he's right down with
it he's playing the drums and music
class he's my teachers like Jesus what
the [ __ ] did this could get this from my
god he didn't get it from me
so I just don't have it I would love to
I was you know that's what I wanted to
be I wanted to be a rock star and then
when I you know when I saw you know
David Lee Roth being funny and interview
and I would go to see Twisted Sister as
a fifteen-year-old and they have to do
five sets a night Andy Snyder's you know
killing time in between and just make it
fun of the audience and going on these
wraps and he's being funny I'm like [ __ ]
man this is cool and then when dice and
Kinnison came out I'm like [ __ ] these
guys like rockstars that's when I was
like I'm doing comedy that's nuts but
cuz I knew I wanted to be onstage you
know somehow because then I couldn't do
it as a musician I tried music I was I
had a good ear for the drums all that
[ __ ] I could still play the drums
naturally just on the natch give me a
couple days of Titan [ __ ] up congas
evening percussion I wanted to play the
guitar but something straight to the
base
I like the bass play cuz he played in
the back nobody in the world is new
yahwah's nobody bothered him and even at
a young age I kind of liked it I was
like this guy don't these people don't
bother nobody
and the bass player still gets chicks
they're still playing he gets to fall
over yeah that's why yeah somebody's
getting his dick sucked he'll get
somebody's to drunk the old one I
something and I went the pastoral music
in Union City and I took lessons there
but I knew as I got older like I was
like I'm switching to a guitar I knew
that with the drug use and just who I
was I knew that I would pawn the guitars
like as I got older I going I'm never
gonna be able to have my guitar because
I'm gonna [ __ ] sell it I'm gonna run
out of money and I'm gonna sell it so I
never really got a good talk but til
this day it's still like up on the
bucket list like just to take a few
lessons and just play you know but I
know that it won't affect me that way
it'll affect me like an addiction right
and then I'll stop breathing it's on the
road I'm not that guy on the plane then
I still carry the guitar that drives me
crazy I hate that guy hate that [ __ ]
guy I know he's gotta get you oh no I
check the [ __ ] guitar yeah if they
break it it's probably your best but
yeah it's not that bad no one knows who
you are so I don't want to do that cuz
I'll bring it the whole time cuz I could
just see myself and hold
9 the finance for the 7 playing [ __ ]
you know I had a move by Pink Floyd the
Sun so yeah that's what scares me we
were talking the transfer addictions I
picked that [ __ ] up like a [ __ ] you
know I just go now as it is like one
week I eat [ __ ] smoothies one week I
[ __ ] he evolves them fight wait
watches why am I [ __ ] gaining weight
right I in an acai berry' laughter I
always got an addiction to something
every week but yeah music it's funny
what we had Rowan's in here and I
watched a bunch of his stuff and he said
something I'm one of the spoken words I
don't know what it is about music that
even lately this you see I was here
yesterday
yeah oh and I came this way last night
I've been coming by lately just put it
out putting the vinyl on it's amazing
you know like just putting Lionel on
reading the lyrics because of something
he said he said that you don't think
about it away before these [ __ ] mutt
joint therapy and the whole therapy
thing you know what our therapy was
going to the record shop with the
[ __ ] money you saved from your paper
route coming home with maybe one of your
buddies smoking a joint and playing that
album back to back to back and then you
beat because there was nothing like
being the first guy had the block to go
I gathered already not bad and then you
gotta can I borrow it not really you
know saying yeah I have you
[ __ ] you gotta walk the hill
like I did you gonna make me [ __ ] but
you know what today is the anniversary
of today's a sad anniversary yeah it's
30 days 30 years since I got since but
today in 1979 the last ones up l'homme
came out in 30 outdoor in through the
out door and it really [ __ ] me up when
I read that today Nikki Sixx puts that
[ __ ] out every day on his little I
follow Nikki on Twitter all this [ __ ]
that happens to him all the pretenders
to release their album telling that was
a great ow yeah I was gonna write out
what birds of paradise but in through
the out door started a [ __ ] chain of
bad luck for me like that was the kiss
of that like I still remember being a
38th Street Park
arguing with mother [ __ ] like in the
evening something he said somebody was
going huh it sounds a little disco ish
that guy that said that I still remember
his name on the way is he almost got a
[ __ ] beating that day at that park
like that's when we argued about music
and Led Zeppelin was the Bible and this
guy was like Alan oh I don't like him
through the outdoor that much that one
song Jimmy pea the Robert Plant says
something shake from me or something
something like dance and this guy was
like that count as son it's not a sound
disco it's like the stone sold out to 70
sexes and invariably just looked at that
[ __ ] but three days later I was
in my hospital that was my birthday
August 18 yeah 71 days later I was in
the [ __ ] hospital for a lung
infection I paraquat dad sprayed the
weeds the government if you grew weed
they sprayed it with a chemical and it
would give you a lung infection I
couldn't play basketball that year then
[ __ ] September like a month later he
died they had John Bonham's on the
bottom died you know six weeks later and
I'll never forget that PLJ that Friday
said we're gonna make an announcement
pretty soon about a tour that
everybody's waiting to hear I'm like
let's that's Led Zeppelin at the garden
that's gonna be ten nights yeah we're
gonna get tickets that's when you got a
mail in a [ __ ] check and get four
tickets in the mail that was because
there was some concerts that you
actually went and stood on line for a
ticket rollin yeah and I don't always go
to Saint Peter's College the Jersey City
chrism is empty empty you can walk right
into the st. Peter's everybody else was
that all these oh oh yeah we gotta go to
the mall like these Brunswick mall we
can try look oh my god and wait outside
of bamberger's and then we have to be
they'd open it up because it'd be a lime
way out the door like the you know the
night before we were in line for like 16
hours so it wasn't like there wasn't a
church or a college near us where we can
go or no one went everyone went there
yeah we went we went
I still double Pink Floyd the wall
without sale we went somewhere first and
the line was around the court my buddy
goes you know what
there's one that st. Peter's Prep nobody
goes there we shot right and walked in
and we got first row up on the top
looking straight at Pink Floyd the first
level up stood perfect yeah you know the
orchestral level lot they were perfect
we just walked in there those tickets
for $15.50 you got you said something
internally when you were fighting did
you guys have friends maybe all the way
up until six seven eighth grade and then
you find out they like a band you don't
like and then the dog done yeah done
absolutely like I had a buddy was a big
van Halen fan and I was in for the ride
but after women and children first we
became enemies for a year like at once I
won in this house I saw the poster on
the wall with David Lee hanging oh yeah
yeah it was kind of inside a woman's
shoe at first he came with a poster yeah
he was hanging in the corner with no
shirt no shirt on yeah if you were a man
you put that face yeah you were man you
put that poster up I wasn't coming to
your house no more you understand me
yeah that definitely well I'm a Jersey
dude
I invite me into your house I look at
two things first off I open up the
refrigerator if you got my Luke hotdogs
in there I'm done with you you better
have sad breaths or something's from the
local paper and those crunchy [ __ ]
hot Oh with the string hanging out all
with a little tail be half with the
mouse tail and then and then I would see
a record collection and if you had cheap
trick or like Jethro Tull in there or
something like that we're gonna have a
problem
yeah I don't know how to exactly look
bad but you like new a journey in there
was yeah we gotta get yeah weird I can't
date you no more okay kid date you know
more like the stones were okay but you
couldn't you couldn't have journey Pat
Benatar was okay you could know I had
Pat and I had to hide them Wow oh yeah
the first time I heard crimes of passion
I got to buy that yeah yeah that's
probably something you would have had
that hide but yeah you couldn't really
have that around your friends but you
have you a journey in there and then
came and well know Kansas was okay I had
a buddy who called a beatin for putting
my sharona hood like he quite a [ __ ]
ferocious be tomorrow from a friend of
mine named John Crowley because Crowley
was tripping on acid and willing to put
on
dark side of the loom because he would
do the whole chandelier bit in the
beginning and this kids like now I'm
putting on my Sharona crack he just held
off from [ __ ] and punched him you know
I had friends that were going to your
house at parties and just like if you
had Springsteen on it they would just
come in take the [ __ ] thing off and
drove the Springsteen album up in the
air like I grew up at that part of the
juries like there was no Springsteen I
had a friend that I friends with since
first grade and well he was a big
metalhead and we go all the shows and
all the sudden they started dating this
girl and he went to a Springsteen shell
I didn't talk to him for two years yeah
that's it seriously I can call him right
now and he'll verified he's like you is
still there you guys you [ __ ] I
got no care you went to see Springsteen
you indices brilliant that was you can't
do that it was unacceptable you just
went saw Sabbath last week you can't go
see David and this is when like that
1984 whatever uh born in the USA came
out with like you know glory days and
[ __ ] dancing in the dark which you
know the horrific song done I think we
didn't talk to you weren't even allowed
to play that enough now there was one
guy who like Springsteen that was the
bartender John Kelly the Frog
cuz he had a little ball under his neck
and he taking on Sunday nights I told
you every time you turned around like he
would have to bartend and have his eye
on everybody like he would take night
and we're coming at you
two Heinekens all right he'll be get
looking around because every time you I
ordered like cocktail if he turned we
throw ice cubes on like if he put our
Springsteen on the jukebox got it like
that was the year when I [ __ ] Motley
Crue release looks to kill yeah that's
the devil his bar where I hung out that
was the loudest record player and he was
proud of it quark you would call a thing
at Corky's the loudest record plan the
tri-state area I mean you couldn't even
talk in there and looks at kill go on
and we would lose it and if any other
song will come out like the dangerous
life was bad with Sheila E yeah he
wasn't big with that one we could live
with yeah but as soon as glory days came
on Born to Run or something we would
start throwing ice cubes at John Kelly
because we knew he's the one that put
that [ __ ] music
the only Springsteen song my life I had
never told nobody it was a
secret I had like him something like if
I sell this right it's the same type of
secret at the big answer if I got leaked
cracking funnies I'd like some fight
anyway I didn't tell nobody I liked that
little Frieza that wasn't a bad song I
loved it though ya know I loved it but I
don't know but now you've got an that
couldn't a little boy I would do I was
doing construction at the time if I was
on a roof putting the roof up and
Springsteen came on the radio was on I
would jump off the roof I wouldn't even
use the ladder to get the [ __ ] shut it
off
okay got a radio to quick estimate that
all that [ __ ] off oh no [ __ ] night
yeah can you guys talk about the jukebox
cuz now it's kind of like I don't know I
don't know if I've ever put one and
maybe once or twice was it a big deal
and the bars when you were going if you
had all music at a jewban while eating
all of your jukebox like the month like
we tell you one time listen bro you got
to start getting some music yeah you
can't have you know [ __ ] Bill Haley
and the Comets [ __ ] that old [ __ ] you
know what I mean it was good but you
don't want to hear another ball for the
ball cause it had Jimmy Buffett on yeah
wasted away margaritas oh that take that
[ __ ] off that [ __ ] doesn't work inside
[ __ ] off take it off right now I'll bust
that button how much what do we do I
spend a night eight nine ten dollars in
quarters because for a quarter you got
three songs oh oh yeah it's a lot of
songs I would play looks to kill three
songs a for a four if I saw a pretty
girl and she came over here's a dollar
go put on a for ten times a for a for a
for a for looks like kill looks the kill
and if you [ __ ] the slip the
Springsteen song in there we were
[ __ ] eyeball using that disco we
listened to disco before [ __ ] spree
yeah cuz the disco you knew if you knew
the songs you can rap with chicks you
might have to dance I'm gonna club and
you're gonna get laid with knowing that
disco stuff said I was okay if some guys
in there he's putting Springsteen and
this goofy [ __ ] in the jukebox we just
loaded up with like [ __ ] $10 worth of
metal so his songs would never even come
up we just keep [ __ ] pound in a way
like Joe we said three songs and over ho
looks the kill looks like killed just so
you wouldn't hear his [ __ ] and then did
you see last week on Twitter I was going
back and forth with a girl named Judy
Kelly and I said Judy we were all
we had some type of time for
conversation issues we've come a long
way and I know we're really old I just
want to apologize for lightening bunny
rabbit on fire and then lack of the car
she had that not ironic bunny rabbit
Oh a stuffed animal thank you I used to
date John Kelly the Frog so they broke
up because she cheated on him down the
shore so he gave her a bunch of stuffed
animals and she put it in the backseat
cuz she was in love him she got drunk
one day and made a mistake and you know
John held it against he would talk to
her right so we're all that one night at
the Cuckoo's Nest up in Nyack New York
before the [ __ ] thought it was anything
there was only two things in Nyack you
went up to just to that club and when I
used to bring the hot cars to Joe the
Arab he was the only Arab but that's one
being an Arab was cool because it was
only one hour yeah if you knew an Arab
they were dynamite you know Joey and me
I know Joey yeah he was all right the
mud Arabs come that nobody likes I'm
saying but then like one too I was
everybody loved Jodie Erin Joanie ever
loved everybody you know he hit you and
my friend yeah you know all the slogans
to [ __ ] him some reaching you didn't
care because it was Joey Arab and you
might doing business with Joey Arab you
know taking cars - Nicky no more [ __ ]
Nicky the [ __ ] you didn't pay me what
he paid with Jody IRA pays me I'm saying
he's tight so that's the only reason I
would go to [ __ ] Nayak so what never up
that coach nothing she's the card doing
coke with us and there's three gorillas
in the back seat and there's a girl in
the front seat Lisa tis and this Judy
Kelly and we're back there talking and
Judy Kelly's she would get drunk and
[ __ ] I'm thinking about John right now
as she put on [ __ ] Bruce and I'll
never forget I've always looked at each
other and I took one of the stuffed
teddy bears and I just lift that
[Laughter]
[ __ ] listen to Bruce get that
[ __ ] off what do you do like you were
walking and you saw like three or four
people in Bruce shirt sorry like ule
though Bruce concert oh say [ __ ] [ __ ]
you your annual I got I got a bumper
stickers made up there is no reason for
Bruce Springsteen and another one the
boss is a total loss
and I got like a hundred of them and I
would walk around I'd stick them all
around the town and if anyone had a
Bruce Springsteen bumper sticker in a
parking lot I cruise parking lots I put
it over their [ __ ] bumper sticker in a
parking lot I was out of my mind I had
bumper stickers I had these stickers at
some of the seventh day god oh yeah like
zap yeah get them at the English Channel
auction [ __ ] funny raisins I would
buy them by the hundreds and if I know
you didn't like Black Sabbath put on
your [ __ ] car week later you'd be out
there with a razor blade like 10 cents
apiece I get stacks of it was Ted Nugent
a great black sassy DC Judas Priest yeah
think about me talk you [ __ ] [ __ ] we
took my music so serious oh yeah then
there was a guy my name with who I still
love guide Tabasco I still talk to him
and he had a brother Mike Tabasco why he
thought he was an event heaven but then
boiling a thought so we would torment
them every day what's going on in the
event he'll and every day they used to
be an argument with the tabasco's and
somebody over Eddie Van Halen we just
told him once Randy Rhoads came out oh
my god we started tormenting at him at
hand with fans but the ones that
suffered the most growing up and I told
this story to Dean though it were Beatle
fans because I still remember taking a
hit of acid going out and my friends
were ho-hum so I went home and my mother
was dead I'm sitting there with mr.
bender tripping my balls off and they
just said John Lennon got shot in front
of the Dakota and I dawg I went to
school the next day now my school they
[ __ ] hated Springsteen but they who
else they hate it was the Beatles John
Lennon wasn't dead 12 hours
I still remember walking into my school
and towards the back by the by the
theater there was a mural of the Beatles
somebody had already put an X through
John Lennon and we were [ __ ] the how
like my school did has it right one
minute to let the beetle know to be
though people know you're [ __ ] done
because at that time there were beetle
people and Springsteen people and they
weren't the same so you always at war
with Springsteen people
we [ __ ] you with the [ __ ] beetle you
go to a party oh let's put on the
paperback right I don't want something
I'm gonna get my dick sucked
I don't want lists a paperback writer
right now where's [ __ ] we once we got
hooked on it was double life gonzo was
the first yeah that was on three two or
three years of the party you can have
whatever you want on your party that we
walked in and then you better put double
live guns or there's gonna be a [ __ ]
problem will you bring your own records
to parties no we would just tell you you
don't have mm gun yeah yeah we gotta go
oh yeah okay we'll go get it my sister's
got it upstairs put it on so his double
I've gone and I tell you what group took
over my town for like the six months
that first time was awesome awesome am a
dizzy b-52s the first down with rock
lobster yeah rock lobster Private Idaho
8081 after Sabbath like when we were
waiting we were in the limbo waiting for
Zee boom b-52s an album I still look
playing I still got well that's great
high 52 girls rock laughs the planet
Claire tough yeah I mean you know they
lost it later what the Love Shack and
[ __ ] like that but no no the debt that
was another thing because you you know
if you couldn't get girls they were in a
hard rock and metal you would get like
New Wave or disco cuz then you could
talk to girls you knew the songs you'd
have to go to the clubs maybe you went
to like the New Wave club or a disco
club to go talk to see it needed to know
that music you weren't getting laid
listen to Bruce Springsteen like you
didn't have to so that then affect us
somebody b-52s definitely cuz New Wave
was starting to play in the clubs and
all the girls will go in there those
clubs so we need to go yeah yeah you go
dance when I'm I went to a whole new way
phase yeah it's like I got you know I
was talking to girls about Judas Priest
and it would just [ __ ] walking away
clients the cars is another love car the
world of ours of cars but I'll tell you
what Van Halen I saw Van Halen and I got
to tell you guys that's a date and a
place I don't remember it was after -
maybe so 70 not between 79 80 cause van
Halen took around 79 after Sabbath like
half the Sabbath broke the right that
was 78 was the first one first van Halen
79 was Van Halen - women and children
was 1980
so I saw them maybe before women and
children and there was a lot of hot
[ __ ] blonde all the van Halen was the
band aborting the chicks there was a lot
hot chick oh yeah but then something
happened 19 [ __ ] 81 I started hanging
at this bar when I was like 16 called
Joel Mary's there was one [ __ ]
that you couldn't talk [ __ ] about are
you were gonna get into a fistfight all
those bars because there were a whole
time this then those bars everything
called white trash people that are very
nice they're just white trash people in
those days before you got there with
your heavy metal [ __ ] they have a guy by
the name of Kenny Rogers on it
and you couldn't touch Kenny Rogers me
Kenny Rogers is for people when you were
18 if you were 30 you were listening to
Kenny Rogers to get your dick sucked and
Iran just put out two or three songs
that a dick-sucker music so one day
believe it or not some guy came up to me
they're all good he goes do you wanna go
see it Kenny Rogers concert at that time
I was a young jim Florentine I want to
see anything I think we do Lewis in the
news yeah there was a time I went to see
anything just for the art of the live
like The Pretenders when she broke a leg
and Coney Island then she did the garden
next to the head she threw the crutches
into the audience I want to see the new
barbarians with the stones
I want to see I want to see James
Brown's at the Palladium and what to see
you to it but I went that just people
that I didn't know it became so open for
me what the [ __ ] was I gonna say what
the [ __ ] were we talking about girls
bars no man what to a Kenny Rogers got
us all right where they got ya that was
the capital of women passing out sucking
dick while it was last out Kenny Rogers
wasn't even giving out Cosby pills [ __ ]
is the pastor not sucking his dick
really dog when he sings lady I'm your
knight in shining armor and I love you
he had like two songs two or three songs
that you look around and women will
[ __ ] crying crying like [ __ ]
crying like ready the sun-baked like
give me give it to me give it to me
give me that [ __ ] [ __ ] juice it was
crazy I left there going oh my god
I just learned about Luke wouldn't like
I'm always a knight and i honest to god
I never want to encanta to pick up a
chick I don't think I ever picked up a
chicken because most of the shows do we
went to there was no only any girls but
then when you started going to show more
shows like that there were I get into
the police the police would draw a lot
of chicks that synchronicity tour all
the women were intuitive it was a big
hit on MTV I got jerked off on like the
20-yard line at a JFK Stadium in Philly
during a police show by some girl I
don't even know watching the show was
the middle of the day I don't know why
the police are on during the day I
remember it being light and she was just
jerking me we're both just watching the
show looking straight ahead and I came I
came on the 21 yard line
did you come on the floor I think
exactly it was six synchronicity to
nowhere right run twenty one round on
the floor you know
oh yeah absolutely I put it right back
in the pocket like it hahaha oh there's
a mushroom between your legs and you got
a rash [ __ ] but that's how was like I
just met some girl there at the show and
then we started making out of where
we're watching a show and she just
jerked me off watching a band it was
great
given that I then I saw go get your beer
and I never came back that's yeah that's
what you told yeah you don't think I'll
just stay here so don't suck your dick
this said the relationships over yeah
what am I gonna do you know we're gonna
go see you on the way what happened to
you yeah I believe it yep I see you in a
park like a little bit of Philly pretzel
I think I know the answer from Joey and
I don't even know if they had him back
then but did you guys go to like any of
these big festivals like camping
festivals for any of these concerts or
no no I went to the Woodstock
Woodstock 1994 they actually had like a
kadai add a comedy tent there oh you
were warmed yeah it was all disorganized
so like nobody even showed up it was
something but but I did go there they
had a bunch of comedians like 20 of us
from New York went out for that we
stayed like the artists tent it was
great they had a co-ed bat co-ed shower
so these girls you know guys and girls
go in the shower like the artist so me
nail the comics were just waiting
outside the shower just [ __ ] waiting
for women to walk in and then we just go
in we took like six hours in one day
would suck me Bob Leavy Don Jameson red
Johnny and a round guy I don't know if
you guys remember those guys from New
York
Danny Vermont who was Danny DeVito Danny
Vermont still writes for police yeah
love Danny I just bumped into a great
dude and he's been a real oh we got rich
Voss one with us Eric McMahan
you know I'm Jersey New York comics most
of the guys are out of the comic strip
but it was like 20 of us took the bus up
there hung out for three days now what
happens if the gym to work was there - I
walked in there for first time in like
ten years
about a month ago it's just I don't know
it's just got a weird vibe to it
I don't do when he sets there what do
you do all your sets when you're the
stand okay
but the stand is moving yeah it's closed
for the summer so I went back to the
Comedy Cellar in the village on the
ground I mean doing sets their music I
just stay at the stand I just love that
Club you let it down to a science
after I spoke to you last week yeah you
go out every two weeks two weeks out it
doesn't have your child yeah well your
son and then there's one week that you
just threw spots of the city yeah I got
I got my son one weekend a month I got
him early in a way I got him 50% of the
time but I got him one weekend I got him
for a full weekend so I take that
weekend off I spend with him I got one
weekend I go I do sets in New York City
and then two weekends I'm on the road so
now like eight days out of a month I'm
home for 22 it works out perfect I did
you learn this balance as you get older
you just like I don't like being out
that long even when I was you know 15 20
years ago doing stand-up I didn't like
being out that long I need to get back
home and just recharge and get away from
it all you know so and now as you get
all these like no I can make my own
schedule I could do whatever the [ __ ] I
want this is before you son and even
yeah before my son but yeah and then you
know I went on tour with those bands
I've got you know I was out for like a
month at a time I hated it 30 days on
the road I don't know how these bands do
it 45 days and [ __ ] being on a bus so I
was like nah man that's not that's not
for me so I just you know two weekends
that's enough I don't want to get burned
out I don't want to get burnt out on me
I don't wanna be doing you know just
feel like a male and an end so recharge
your batteries just [ __ ] hang on my
son play you know do anything but comedy
don't think anything but comedy I hang
out my neighbors they live in the
suburbs and we just talk [ __ ] you
know schools and just get away from it
all and then when I'm ready to get back
up there I'm recharged yeah I had to cut
it down the two weeks in love I had the
perfect balance right now because first
I was to him two weeks a month but this
[ __ ] will do two back-to-back
have a week off and then two
back-to-back so I was really doing five
four out of five right that's still
murder
that's yes still murder so I look and
see what works for me and now yeah I
love to go on every [ __ ] weekend they
do like Thursday Friday Saturday
you love it come on Sunday I can't I
can't but you do it you do two weekends
a month in the ruins a month yeah and my
body it takes four days like right today
I feel great like today I feel great for
two days my sleep was off I still worked
out I still did what I had to do but
today was [ __ ] great I am tip-top
Magoo now I got another week then I
gonna have a Bama next Thursday then I
go to Nashville Friday and Saturday and
I'm home two weeks yep you know I like
that and people agents get mad at your
whatever you know what man I got a
family and I'm a different animal now I
wish just would have happening that
dirty to you right see me if this
happened at 32 yeah yeah you were the
same way I'm gonna point on Tuesday
picking up a one night and Wednesday
Thursday Sally getting in town a day
before why not a day before the good
steak go around the town go to a record
store you got it and you do Kansas City
at all I haven't done in a while
books I don't know I love the city
because damn whoa Dean doe ray went to
this [ __ ] vintage t-shirt store in
Kansas City they got you know drop a
grand you're gonna drop it oh it's the
ones where they cost like 150 did a real
shirt the real shirt okay
the real church I mean he had he was
sending me pictures they had the shirt I
bought the opening line a Pink Floyd the
baseball shirts because the papal
baseball shirts got popular 400 you had
a baby out of baseball you had 11 white
Pink Floyd one than a friend
mind still had about ten years ago and
had shrunk it was like a baby sure yeah
you can't believe like good morning yeah
no and it was still a excel or hell it
was like a tell but the [ __ ] cotton
that shrunk over the years the moth
Anita where I had Ted Nugent weekend
warriors in a baseball jersey did yeah
yeah I remember and then after a while
like you know ten years after that that
you can't fit in them so I went up
chocolate on one time I never should
have done that I know tons of them
blizzard of aahhhs with the crosses on
the back of the shirt with the tour
dates and all that for markets and [ __ ]
yeah I did all that I had a friend that
used to make t-shirts he worked with a
sporting goods called levees and that's
what he did he really was a stock boy
but he even [ __ ] get high and make
the shirts and we'd all wear the same
shirts to a concert like the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
Asya wore suicide solution with two
lines of coke on it I mean people must
have thought me and my friends are
[ __ ] [ __ ] Lee I thank God was
dead that was on paper they look like
two joints right but there are really
two lines of coke like he forgot to put
the straw next to it but it was like we
had a shirt that said instead of the
front said Judas Priest but the back
would say Jesus Christ which meant
choose from right yeah yeah [ __ ]
Eamon used to make all these shirts and
people come up to us and go where'd you
get them I wish I saved those shirts
today cuz nobody had no money
nobody he'd do this weird stuff where he
cut a picture out of Tony Iommi do this
do that this is before computers Lee
this is my copying machine and [ __ ]
hand and it was like that I mean Tony
Iommi he look like Fidel we used to go
find him and go who's that he did our
Black Sabbath and we would laugh but it
didn't matter and he would make 10
shirts for every show for us I strip him
he made him for yes let me yes he's a
I'm to a garden every year our kids do
like ten [ __ ] nights I was never a
big yes vanos too it was too cerebral
for me I like I like some earnest a
couple of songs but I roundabout yeah
yeah all that [ __ ] you know they got
more commercial
along it hard and all that stuff later
I'll never forget that I went I was
going to see them for a while like I
remember going in the 8th grade gonna
see him being pissed cos out of Miss
roots roots was on the same week as I
had seen like two nights of roots and I
was hooked I wanted to see what happened
with me after America but yes played but
yes played like six nights at the garden
and the first couple of years I went to
see yes it was always bad and then the
last two or three years people were
giving you seats like yes was coming too
much yeah yeah coming every year
September 14 they came every year the
week that school started that's what I
remember about yes I'll kind of they
always came to the garden September 1st
2nd 3rd 4th 5th five [ __ ] nights did
you go see Judas Priest
I'm the British steel tour a five nights
in a row at the Palladium no I I think I
was living in Florida at the time it was
1988
so I saw him at the Meadowlands what
Iron Maiden maybe I guess it was maybe
scream for vengeance tour that's a fun
adventure no no I saw him earlier with
Maiden what Paul Tiana what that's right
I was the Lady of you yeah no I had
convention hall in Asbury okay now you
see the world at the Palladium with that
I don't think so I maybe I might have
saw that killers at the Palladium but I
don't know if it was if they were
opening up for that's why I asked you
when you said ac/dc August 4th August
1st 1980 I wasn't sure cause it was AZ
these-- but I wasn't sure if it was Def
Leppard touring high and you know was
definitely definitely buffered because I
moved like the Florida like August 28th
1980 so I was still around in the area
to see those shows before I moved I see
Black Sabbath would do it's their third
third show ever
right I don't like that Theo took over
Ozzy's place I was an Ozzy guy so I was
like I was mad but Heaven and Hell comes
out it's a great record so I'm like you
know what I gotta give it to him I was
rooting for it to fail I was just and I
was totally [ __ ] [ __ ] Ronnie James Dio
Ozzy I remember Miami arena me and my
brother go and
for to show we stopped off a like some
parties storm we got a tablecloth of
white tablecloth and we get a black
magic marker and we make up our own sign
and we write Ozzie is God deal must pray
to him for forgiveness
we sneak it in the Miami arena was like
general mission it was only like 3,000
people there of Sabbath was kind of that
they decline that and you know they're
just starting to make a comeback and we
get like in the second row and deal
comes out he they open up with war pigs
and I'm mad I still think Aziz your
mouth
I still think Oz he's gonna come out for
some reason I'm like cuz there was no
internet back then so you didn't know I
knew he was at Alabama no Mike you never
know maybe Ozzie will come out and they
all three of them come out Bill Ward
olds guys and then all of a sudden do
comes out a little short guy a little
short guy so we're holding the battery
doing all this [ __ ] go generals Gavin in
their messes yeah and he was [ __ ] up
the song cause he had the peace signs
that was cool deal had that the medals
of the horns the Maluku good now but you
know at that time was like come on man
yeah it's adoration of whatever it is of
Ozzie to peace signs the peace signs
were cool so we're holding the sign up
right and in deal come over and look at
he's giving us two fingers I [ __ ] you
had to sign Mirabella holdin it up and
he's gonna pretend like he's jerking off
[ __ ] you guys by the second song two-bit
big black security guys come here and
take us [ __ ] bring us in the back they
bring my brother in a room I'm like
what's 15 at the time 16 they bring him
in a back room like these three big guys
and it and they lock the door and I'm
crying I leave my brother alone foot cuz
they're holding me back they wouldn't
let me in there five minutes later they
bring him out bring me to bring the
suicide door they throw us out in the
[ __ ] Park a lot like garbage we got
kicked out of the show because [ __ ]
deal was complaining over - over a sign
now I never told them see I now I'm
friends with do because I'm I know Rudy
Rudy introduces him me and then he's on
that metal show I'm like I can't tell
him that story cuz about a year before
he died this is 25 years later he does
an hour an article in a magazine they go
did you get any backlash from when you
replaced Asya it's not a fans are pretty
cool go psyche of remember one time it
was early on the tour there's a there
was a sign this banner was really
bugging me something about like Ozzie is
God and I got a pray
- um for something I got it just really
was getting under my skin I [ __ ] it
drove me crazy go so there was some
times with that and I'm like holy [ __ ]
that was the [ __ ] of my banner
mine are my brothers banner but I could
never tell deal because I've become you
know kind of friendly with him I can't
go hey I was that [ __ ] [ __ ] at 16
that angry kid that was mad that you
were in the band and not Ozzy everybody
was this was a very weird feeling for
people because it was almost it was it
for the Black Sabbath and Ozzy and do it
was almost like Trump Hillary you were
on one side or the other and I was that
and you'd [ __ ] fight somebody
I still remember doing the acid and
stopping on a magazine store and there
was an article in there about Sabbath
that just drew me over the loop like had
nothing I had no parents at the time and
my whole life was listening to Black
Sabbath Black Sabbath was keeping the
glue together as scary as his sound it
was all Sabbath bloody Sabbath nobody
will ever tell you the reasons why right
that's it yeah that's it I bought it
hook line and sinker I'm not gonna lie
to anybody and tell you that was my glue
that was my therapist that whole album
the National Acrobat and that were
keeping me together and all of a sudden
when I saw Black Sabbath up the first
time they were terrible Ozzy was
terrible so I didn't know what to think
I left there like I lost face like I was
never said diet or ever say yeah I like
that's like wearing a jersey to watch
your team and he sucks and you gotta
walk home with a [ __ ] jersey on its
front everybody and everybody on the bus
was talking about that guitar play in
the first band and you know like god
damn it and then he disappeared for a
while nobody knew what was happening how
he got thrown out of the band nobody
knew and then we found that they got
they had a singer which I always play
that was horrible the first singer after
Ozzy oh yeah Dave Walker
oh just god-awful yeah he was god off
yeah I sound like diarrhea yeah and then
they said somebody opens whatever am i
buying rainbow rising and listening to
him going
I don't think this is gonna work wait
this ain't gonna work
this is not gonna work this do Ozzie
collaboration this do Sam's
collaboration is not gonna [ __ ] work
and then the album came out and it was
it's like it's like Eve [ __ ] it's not
kosher but you do it anyway you don't
say I'm right if the chick told you eat
my ass on I'll suck your dick you tell
bend over I eat that [ __ ] thing
well if I find the peanut whatever I
find that you don't suck my dick yeah
it's it was something that you wanna pay
like I wanted to hate Heaven and Hell
absolutely all my heart but it just
every time you listen to it today I with
the crowd there opee
when I came in I'll write the fries and
tie the guy goes what do you want to
hear that you happen to know because you
haven't played that in a while
because I got to a number down the
kicked right so I going there throw
punches cuz at least some Madonna you
could dance around but heaven hell just
having to help I go and they throw kicks
twists I'm doing black flips in the
[ __ ] air yeah I love that hold now
today when I left deal I was pissed that
drive from Philly back to the left
Bergen was a [ __ ] long drive we were
like the my future yeah because he
wasn't singing the songs right no he
wasn't
and we're mad like come on singing like
Ozzy if you're gonna do it but he was
cool he could he was trying to do his
interpretation I don't never forget that
when he came he's like generals gathered
and then messes yeah just like which is
that black masses I'm like Oh how's he
doing you know like [ __ ] a savage
like John Osborne would do it yelling
and screaming and [ __ ] clapping and
[ __ ] hangin you know come on let's go
your [ __ ] measly bastards put your
hands together on your high saw my smoke
those joints oh yeah yeah yeah he was
yelling Chicago and it was you know I
still remember having live at last time
when you bought the bootleg live at last
they had that we talk about all the time
east-west and uh hey by the way by the
[ __ ] way this happened just so you
know I saw it had for you coming
to San Diego or whatever the [ __ ] on
Twitter last Saturday it was a general
thing on somebody else's feed or your
feed right and what I whaling on that's
interesting Jim come to town and when I
flipped over to my feed guess it was in
the picture a picture of the building
across the street from Hudson County
Park the tall building with the grinder
where they saw the Martians from oh yeah
yeah I thought and they go show Jimmy
Florentine this picture and I go let me
call this [ __ ] he's come on the
podcast that's man that's what happened
that's how that was Saturday Saturday a
Friday I was yeah robustly yeah that's
how weird it was that one minute you
were saying you were doing a show and
I'm my other thread it was a guy that
stopped at the light and took a picture
of that building Wow said the ghost
building were you and Jimmy Florentine
talked about over here
no that Black Sabbath thing was
something that today if we ever go to
therapy it'll come up like eventually
after a year they'll say so what
happened earlier you know I caught my
mother sucking your dick but when Ozzy
left Sabbath there was history
traumatized ever so yeah I mean
devastated speaker like when the diver
Manman the record came out I'd have to
listen to that song die every man man
before I go to school in 11th grade I
hated it I was a bad place my life we
just moved I had no friends I was in a
private Catholic school in Florida
didn't know anyone all the kids were
rich I had long hair that drive around a
Mercedes I had a shitty beat-up
Volkswagen what black sabbath's bumper
stickers and Judas Priest and I had no
friends and I would listen that song
every day to get me through it before I
went to school that [ __ ] song is
unbelievable the diss all guy ever man
man is [ __ ] off the guitar home when he
shakes up the second verse love it like
it opens up slowly with like piano was
something to harp and then he comes down
now man no no no no
now now here's the weird thing about
that
I guess his mother taught in Burbank
yeah
his mother talked guitar and bareback so
just recently maybe ten years ago I
don't know somebody who came in here and
was talking about guitar lessons
it's got Quinn and Quinn because I did
Quinn study with Joe Satriani so he said
yeah Randy Rhoads was I never called oh
man can you imagine that like that kid
and he talked guitar lessons and then
Joey cryin and I saw the album yesterday
I almost got it we can have it
look what the mental health okay yes
he's gone by that yeah yeah yeah he was
well I wanted to buy the album what's
the one he's on he's on um what the one
before would slick black Cadillac
slipped back down active yeah I forget
what it was without him before him would
know wasn't they weren't big in Japan it
was so crazy that the one I have is well
number one selling hounds in a long time
that was the first heavy metal record to
hit the number one in the Billboard
charts is Quiet Riot metal hell right
that's what yeah first album ever have
him at open I got a something between
you and I his friends and you know I
love Rudy it drives me crazy sometimes
whenever I hear and I believe Trump bang
yo hey man oh it drives me crazy right
too much so you guys know to me like I
think there's a difference between life
and I think you guys are fans you
sounded like experts almost to me oh oh
you sound like you were more than fans
well you had to know your stuff like you
know if you were gonna go and you were
to challenge somebody you better know
you better know to back it up
you better [ __ ] know yeah like if you
gonna get into arguments like hey this
there's a bunch of shows I went to see
like I get people still bust my balls
like you were wrong on that date but you
were close you know at least I'm in the
neighborhood
I still remember going what was the
place I saw missing persons that I love
that band I saw them there and 81 maybe
82 83 whatever the big album was popular
what was the big album with walking in
that way yeah that ring session at me
upper in session and I so noticeable one
all my sauna
that opens up its fine yarn that opens
it up I've had rain enough who's uh
Terry's son oh he dropped his son he
also plays the drum with great kitties
on Facebook we talked from the time to
time but guess who I went to see there
one night I'm in white and I'm
embarrassed it's like no you know what
I'm really embarrassed about two things
I'll let you going now you gotta get
those descending or one I didn't really
like let me when they opened for
frosting was it really I'm like what is
this what is this [ __ ] junk this is
Chuck this is John well cuz you're we
simply understand super loud right and
just [ __ ] a hundred miles an hour and
you're like what yeah I could see now I
like it now i like Lemmy and they
understand what he stood for and the
whole [ __ ] deal
in fact that he does a show and he
trunks is doing on the residency at the
at the rainbow at the rainbow yeah I'm
gonna try to go up there and see him
live when he comes back I thought it was
every Friday and [ __ ] August I was
misinformed I was gonna try to go
tonight okay yeah no I think he doesn't
want a month yeah I was gonna take my
wife and watch he's like well yeah I
don't see each other
I told his wife that he's drunk I'm
gonna go watch him live it has some
creepy [ __ ] questions where are you
so tonight you're in San Diego tonight
San Diego then I got Atlantic City to
Newhart the Hard Rock Casino open in
Atlantic City
how is it I haven't been there yet but
I'm doing three nights there Howie
Mandel I guess holds the club is the
Howie Mandel comedy club so August 28th
through the 30th me and Don Jameson
heard air and then I'm doing the funny
bone in Albany September 13th through
15th hustler middle doing he's doing
great he's on tour what faster pussycat
Christ he's up for three months on the
tour bus he just 20 minutes to stand up
but he brings up the band
he sits a [ __ ] he's an animal he's a
say yeah he says he's on the tour bus
with those guys they'd [ __ ] just rage
and drink like they're 20 years old he's
on it for three months and he plays
these rock clubs wherever they are to
get like eight you know anywhere between
like three hundred to a thousand
and he does you know in the crowd he
does 20 minutes to stand up in front of
those animals and then he brings on the
band I just want to tell you the only
guys that listen on my serious listen to
lithium you Jim and what's-his-name
and I love your shows I love when you
tell stories but the one that you got me
was with the Cherry Bomb and I sat there
i guess because i didn't hear from you
for years and you got a message to me
goes dude I was at that show oh my god
oh my god yeah I cried my wife got in
the car said we crying about people
could validate my [ __ ] stories I
remember that [ __ ] Cherry Bomb I also
remember when the good rats opened up
for the Aerosmith at the garden
something to a Cherry Bomb edge and Joe
Perry and he [ __ ] got off stage I
remember a lot of [ __ ] number last thing
I want to ask you is how much do people
talk to you about that metal show
oh it's Jesus Christ it's insane like
people really and I miss it kind of like
watches if I was doing that it was a
great guest I'd watch it yeah well you
know with luck we were on we did 140
episodes who were on for eight seven
eight years you know a TV TV Tom that's
amazing to be on that long and
eventually you know show runs its course
but meanwhile you know his Viacom the
company that was a vh1 classic only
would just [ __ ] the bed you know said I
had to come in and make some major cuts
and pretty much of most of the original
programming got cut including our show
and it's a good buy we got you know
we're losing a [ __ ] ton of money in
this company known as MTV all that other
[ __ ] so it was more of a corporate
decision but people still come out look
me Don and Eddie were three hosts of the
show a heavy-metal talk-show we have no
say in the matter like where it goes you
can't please go up to an actor you know
do you think people go up to Jennifer
Aniston look you should get friends on
Netflix you know where they going out
together Feeny after Sopranos go away
you ever try Showtime
yeah what about hula just a new you know
well just do want you guys put it on
YouTube do Sopranos for you too you know
what it means like you have there's so
many other people that control that like
we don't own the show we just can't go
hey my friend works at HBO he wants to
show you know citizeness you know red
tape once in a while shows do come back
absolutely I mean it's
niche audience you know we're
interviewing Lita Ford you know we're
not gonna go on after UFC fighting on
you know and spike or something like
that or USA Network because it's a whole
different audience so if we find a
channel I don't know at some point but
who knows I mean someone will have to
get acquire two rights from vh1 who owns
the show and have to pay them for vh1 to
give them the rights and then they could
put it on their network it remember
Howard Stern did those old channel 9
show I was back in the day they were
[ __ ] classic they were incredible
channel 9 owns that stuff owns those
shows they never gave them back to
Howard Stern wanted to buy and to put
them out on DVD they would never let
they go nope
he probably offered a millions of
dollars in channel 9 just said nope [ __ ]
you you know getting them and he never
he could never release them because they
own them so vh1 basically owns the show
Viacom so at some point some network is
interested they enough to go to them go
hey his 250,000 we have the show and all
the back catalog that's how it would
work if it ever came back I would do it
look we love it but you know at this
point there's nothing he could do him I
was the coolest guy you Miller of the
show I mean we had we had Iommi
everybody Mio me everybody every [ __ ]
Bill Ward Steve Harris from Iron Maiden
we and we had Angus and Bryant we had
Angus and Brian Johnson on when the
black ice album came out like a 2008 our
first season we interviewed those guy I
mean that's insane
it's a who's playing the guitar in the
back like yeah we had different guys
with Ted Nugent we had Ted Nugent I
always say he's probably my favorite
guest cuz I never met him in 76 with the
you know what was the concert that [ __ ]
when he's outside that the California
Jam from California yeah he's out there
with the [ __ ] rabbit tail and he's
got no shirt on and his [ __ ] hair is
all over the place and he's singing cat
scratch fever Motor City man house I was
a I was addicted at 12 years old like
this is [ __ ] holy [ __ ] so I and then
he comes on that metal show when he was
did you know no didn't talk politics or
any guns or in a shed just a funny dude
talking about music and then went up
there and jammed for like the last 10
minutes of the show just [ __ ] took
his guitar and just jam it was funny
because vh1
that we weren't allowed to play any
original music because then they have to
pay rights for they have to pay
royalties on it too cheap they didn't
want to pay any so anyone that came out
we
play any other songs any the guitar
players couldn't play any licks to their
songs because then they would have to
pay a royalty to that band they go we're
not doing that Ted comes on he goes look
I want to play my songs and they go you
can he goes I own all my music they go
you still can because no I'm I own it I
I say it's okay
you can play they go no we gotta go look
I'll sign it give me a [ __ ] piece of
paper I want to place on my ribs and
they still wouldn't let him do it but
anyway we're going up there in jam for
truck in 20 minutes and I'm watching
Nugent just you know ten feet away
just rip it on that guitar it's
phenomenal and then Kirk Hammet came on
with Michael Schenker oh I knew Mike was
shaking that balloon there Michael
Schenker a Kirk hammer from Metallica is
a huge Michael Schenker fan so we're
gonna have Michael Schenker on he's
gonna play guitar so Eddie calls up Kirk
Hammett ed he's drunk because he knows
courteous hey Kirk I'm gonna have
Michael Schenker come on if you guys
want to jam together Kirk's like what
yeah I could jam with wood with Michael
Schenker's I guess so Kirk goes I'll
come there for free whatever he flew to
New York and they [ __ ] jam I saw the
video yeah you told me about the video
yeah so cuz he was such a big Michael
Schenker fan he was geeking out and we
had them together and they both played
they worked something out before the
show and just [ __ ] and play it on the
show said I was amazing too bro always a
pleasure to have absolutely dude you're
one of my favorites man without anyhow
the Musa legend is taking me back and
you always welcome you know many people
come out to my comedy shows go dude I
heard you on Joey's podcast [ __ ]
great yeah we're having like oh you two
guys it's [ __ ] up it goes I don't you
know you tell these stories like there's
no way it's true he goes but we know
they are when you're first him like
there's no way that happened this is the
cherry bomb like nobody else remembers
this [ __ ] I'm gonna be in Huntsville at
levity live next Thursday night and then
Friday and Saturday I am in the
[ __ ] Nashville at Zanies where
are you at man yeah I got an Atlantic
City next week okay August 28th you I
thought Hard Rock yeah yeah I'm down
come live like I know Albany I got
Cuyahoga Falls in Ohio I got some
Florida dates I'm doing Miami Boca so
jim Florentine calm my book everybody is
awful except you was in stores and it's
on Amazon I love you guys have a great
weekend stay black and don't forget
if you need some supplements always go
to audit comm from alpha brain shroom
tax room to export room check immune
listen I got you covered
I fly every two weeks you don't see me
[ __ ] coughing number one I ain't
asked number two why slamming Hudson and
number three I eat a shrimp Tek a meal
and I've to walk around little Japanese
guy with a [ __ ] mask on my face at
the [ __ ] Airport so go to [ __ ]
honey calm and press in church bad we
get 10% off also my family my D family
over Fuji Sports calm I love your
[ __ ] are on my heart whether
it's the rash guards the the [ __ ]
shin guards knee pads whatever you need
Fuji's got a great price and a low and
yeast eighty dollars to the super Reno's
to 120 to the psycho 2.0 we got your
covered go to Fuji sports.com right now
in press in charge bad and get 10% off
delivered to your crib will see your
[ __ ] next week have a great
weekend jim Florentine thank you again
for coming on jim Florentine calm yeah
and then on my podcast comedy mental
midgets out every way tell yeah no
thanks man and I'm a big fan of what he
does love you Jim thank you very much
finds you don't kill no [ __ ]
Christians this week
stay black kick this [ __ ] meal leave